>>> WELCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION.
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
THE JANUY 6th COMMITTEE JUST
TALKED TO ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WORKED MOST CLOSELY WITH THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE FORMER
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL,ING PAT
CIPOLLONE.
WE'RE LEARNING THIS MORNING THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS WAIVING CLAIMS
OF EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE FOR STEVE
BANNON, WHO IS NOW INDICATING HE
MIGHT BE WILLING TO TESTIFY IN
PUBLIC.
JOINING ME NOW IS A MEMBER OF
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSWOMAN ZOE LOFGREN OF
CALIFORNIA.
CONGRESSWOMAN, LET ME START WITH
THAT NEWS ABOUT STEVE BANNON
WE'RE LEARNING THIS MORNING.
WILL BANNON TESTIFY BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE?
AND WHAT SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
MIGHT YOU HAVE FOR HIM?
>> WELL, WE GOT THE LETTER
AROUND MIDNIGHT FROM HIS LAWYER
SAYING THAT HE WOULD TESTIFY.
AND WE HAVE WANTED HIM TO
TESTIFY, SO THE COMMITTEE, OF
COURSE, HAS NOT YET HAD A CHANCE
TO DISCUSS IT, BUT I EXPECT THAT
WE WILL BE HEARING FROM HIM.
AND THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS WE
HAVE FOR HIM.
>> WOULD IT BE A PUBLIC HEARING
OR BEHIND CLOSED DOORS?
>> ORDINARILY, WE DO
DEPOSITIONS, YOU KNOW, THIS GOES
ON FOR HOUR AFTER HOUR AFTER
HOUR.
WE WANT TO GET ALL OUR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED, AND YOU CAN'T DO THAT
IN A LIVE FORMAT.
>> YOU HEARD FROM ANOTHER KEY
WITNESS THIS WEEK, WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL PAT CIPOLLONE, WHO SAT
WITH YOU ON FRIDAY.
YOUR COMMITTEE SAID HE GAVE
CRITICAL TESTIFY THAT SHOWS,
QUOTE, DONALD TRUMP'S SUPREME
DERELICTION OF DUTY, UNQUOTE.
WHAT DOES THE COMMITTEE MEAN BY
THAT?
AND WILL WE HEAR EXCERPTS OF
CIPOLLONE'S TESTIMONY IN THIS
WEEK'S HEARINGS?
>> YES, WE WILL HAVE SOME
EXCERPTS OF MR. CIPOLLONE'S
TESTIMONY.
HE WAS ABLE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON BASICALLY ALL OF
THE CRITICAL ISSUES WE'RE
LOOKING AT.
AND INCLUDING THE PRESIDENT'S,
WHAT I WOULD CALL DERELICTION OF
DUTY, ON THE DAY OF JANUARY 6th.
SO, YES, THAT WAS IMPORTANT.
AS YOU KNOW, THE COMMITTEE RULES
DON'T ALLOW US TO DISCLOSE THE
TESTIMONY WITHOUT A VOTE OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED YET.
BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT TESTIMONY.
>> DID HE DISCUSS TRUMP
CONSIDERING SEIZING THE VOTING
MACHINES OR TRUMP CONSIDERING
DECLARING MARTIAL LAW TO SEIZE
THE VOTING MACHINES?
>> I THINK YOU'LL HAVE TO WAIT
FOR THE HEARING LATER THIS WEEK.
AS I SAID, WE HAVEN'T HAD A VOTE
TO DISCLOSE THE TESTIMONY.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS, I THINK HE
DID PROVIDE IMPORTANT INSIGHTS
ON THOSE SUBJECTS.
>> FORMER MARK MEADOWS' AIDE
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAID
CIPOLLONE SAID SOMETHING ALONG
THE LINES, THEY WOULD BE CHARGED
WITH EVERY CRIME IMAGINABLE IF
TRUMP WENT UP TO THE CAPITOL.
TWO SOURCES TOLD CNN THAT THE
COMMITTEE DID NOT ASK PAT
CIPOLLONE WHETHER HE SAID THAT.
IS THAT TRUE?
IF SO, WHY WOULDN'T YOU ASK HIM
THAT?
>> WE NEVER CALL IN WITNESSES TO
CORROBORATE OTHER WITNESSES OR
TO GIVE THEIR REACTION TO OTHER
WITNESSES.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT HE DID
INTERVIEW WITH US FOR EIGHT
HOURS AND PROVIDE VERY
INSIGHTFUL INFORMATION.
AND THAT AUGMENTS AND CERTAINLY
DOES NOT DISPUTE MISS
HUTCHINSON'S TESTIMONY.
SO, STAY TUNED FOR THIS WEEK'S
HEARINGS.
WE THINK THEY'LL BE WORTH
ATTENDING.
>> WE JUST LEARNED FROM FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS THAT OATH KEEPERS,
THAT FAR RIGHT MILITIA GROUP,
BROUGHT EXPLOSIVES TO THE D.C.
AREA AROUND JANUARY 6th.
WILL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ULTIMATELY SEE A DIRECT LINK
BETWEEN DONALD TRUMP AND THESE
FAR RIGHT MILITIA GROUPS, SOME
OF THE MEMBERS HAVE BEEN CHARGED
WITH SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY?
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE CONNECTING
THE DOTS DURING THESE HEARINGS,
BETWEEN THESE GROUPS AND THOSE
WHO WERE TRYING IN GOVERNMENT
CIRCLES TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
SO, WE DO THINK THAT THIS STORY
IS UNFOLDING IN A WAY THAT IS
VERY SERIOUS AND QUITE CREDIBLE.
>> WE HEARD CASSIDY HUTCHINSON
TESTIFY ALONG THE LINES OF TRUMP
TELLING MARK MEADOWS, THE CHIEF
OF STAFF, TO TALK TO ROGER STONE
AND OTHERS, MIKE FLYNN, AND
STONE AND FLYNN HAD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SOME OF THESE
FAR RIGHT MILITIA GROUPS.
ARE THOSE THE DOTS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CONNECTING?
>> SOME OF THEM.
BUT CERTAINLY THERE ARE -- YOU
KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO BE MAKING
SOME CONNECTIONS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE FULL RUN OF THE
EVENTS AND THE EVENTS LEADING UP
TO THE 6th.
SO, YES, I HOPE THAT OUR HEARING
ON TUESDAY WILL BE ENLIGHTENING
ON THESE ISSUES.
>> WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP AWARE
THAT THESE FAR RIGHT MILITIA
GROUPS, THE PROUD BOYS AND OATH
KEEPERS, WERE IN THE MOB WHEN HE
TOLD THE MOB TO GO TO THE
CAPITOL?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU HAVE TO
REACH YOUR OWN CONCLUSIONS, BUT
BASED ON THE EVENTS LEADING UP
TO THE DAY, I THINK THAT WOULD
BE A LOGICAL CONCLUSION.
>> OATH KEEPERS' FOUNDER STUART
RHODES SAID THROUGH HIS ATTORNEY
ON FRIDAY THAT HE'S WILLING TO
TESTIFY TO YOUR COMMITTEE BUT
ONLY IF IT'S LIVE AND IN PUBLIC.
WILL YOU TAKE HIM UP ON THAT
OFFER?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE HE'S IN
PRISON RIGHT NOW, ISN'T HE,
BEING HELD FOR HIS TRIAL?
SO, THIS MAY BE A PITCH TO BE
RELEASED.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY HAD INFORMATION FROM
MR. RHODES.
>> YOU HAVE INFORMATION FROM
MR. RHODES, HE'S ALREADY
TESTIFIED BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
SEPARATELY?
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO GO INTO
ALL THE DETAILS, BUT I THINK
THIS IS A PITCH TO GET OUT OF --
GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD FOR
MR. ZOOEDZ BEFORE WE GO, WE KNOW
ABOUT THE HEARINGS COMING THIS
TUESDAY.
I BELIEVE THERE'S ANOTHER ONE
EXPECTED THURSDAY IN THE
EVENING.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
ANY FUTURE HEARINGS?
WILL THIS BE THE END OF IT OR DO
YOU EXPECT MORE HEARINGS TO
COME, PERHAPS, LATER IN THE
MONTH OR EVEN IN AUGUST?
>> WELL, I ALWAYS LET THE
CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR MAKE THE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ON HEARINGS.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS, WE'RE
WORKING OVER THE WEEKEND TO PUT
THE FINAL TOUCHES ON THE HEARING
FOR TUESDAY.
THERE IS SO MUCH INFORMATION,
IT'S OVERWHELMING, REALLY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE AN HOUR HEARING,
SO WE'LL HAVE A REPORT TOWARDS
THE FALL, I BELIEVE.
WHETHER THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
HEARINGS, WE HAVEN'T DECIDED
THAT YET.
>> WHO ARE WE GOING TO HEAR FROM
ON TUESDAY?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO ANNOUNCE THE
WITNESSES TODAY.
>> IT WAS WORTH A SHOT.
CONGRESSWOMAN ZOE LOFGREN,